my mother beautifully squeezing me out
of a vagina say that penny I came out
like a rock
[Music]
I'm Keeley Walla bridge hi I'm Tandy
Newton about Amelia talk here's been the
biggest influence on your career and why
oh my goodness
mm just I feel like the others went in
front of me yeah I guess my main
inspiration for when I was playing
Dragons is just so many don't you feel
because we got away I get asked this
question you're a man and you're like
well everyone from my mum to my best
friend the nor Efron and also correct
yeah yeah it's looser behind the
artistic side because career also
implies just like you know like I
thought you'd helped you get there yeah
Cruise and exactly you know even you
know agents and these people that have
been so important in shaping it yeah so
that's kind of open to interpretation so
right so many people yeah what was the
most pivotal moment that changed your
life and got you to where you are today
for Arnie's crazy but I know the most
and got you to where you are today
my mother beautifully
squeezing me out of her vagina yeah I
think coming out of my mother's vagina
was my biggest man funny I came out like
a rocket baby chewy
I was cut open and removed well come on
that's even more worried yeah a friend
of mine asked me to do a like a short
like a little 10 minute thing in a night
of 10 minute things yes you know writing
yourself and and doing the monologue and
I did it and then it went down well that
night and that was the first 10 minutes
of what that and became free Bible just
to show that I've entered play no no
tended to eat oh yeah that's it was it
was whitey taking the nican writing my
name is really late it was at the point
where I had very happily decided that I
wasn't gonna keep acting I'm really Zen
about it I was like 43 I had just ended
a contract with a TV show and I started
writing and I really loved it I had a
Skype conversation with the creators of
Westworld and they started off by saying
she's nervously mm-hmm
but anyway just joking aside it just was
such an phenomenally progressive and
exciting idea and that was it 43 and
about to give up but like I said happily
baby on the boob two goons other kids
I'm like writing loving it and as an
actress that was it two years ago three
years ago mines weird because it sort of
I was very very very very very very very
lucky
the first big job I did was Game of
Thrones and it was successful it went
well and so that changed everything and
every single season I just was learning
and learning and learning on the pure
brain as it were like I'm not gonna get
emotional to say this but losing my dad
very recently I think has changed
everything is too changed Who I am now
it's changed my perspective on life and
it's changed what I want my career to go
what advice would you give to your
younger self can be on career love
relationships or just like plenty how
long have you got darling don't know try
that much don't blade with a bunch of
really really really good yeah yeah
don't chemically straighten your hair
immediate though how would you describe
yourself to someone who has never met or
heard of other do you mind person yeah
get out of the way good oh no she's
alright
oh she's alright alright you know
actually yes genuinely very very I think
the reason I said that is because we
tend to make judgements and then that
they always change to it for a lot
sometime so she's all right means I may
not have thought that or whatever I did
think and something
yes changed him that's really beautiful
that's really like good yeah and she
didn't scare me genuinely struggling
with this one
will you please my instinct was to be
like awkward like how about this how
about I write of you and you describe me
okay Emilia Clarke is she is this
incredible force that you are a true
force of good but is a good and you make
you give people energy when you around
them if I can Emilia make it like that's
great that's really really nice how I
would describe Phoebe is you carry with
you such grace genuinely but you have
like you carry yourself with such Grace
and such sensitivity of people you've
got so much in you you you see you see
some when it comes down to karaoke songs
but you know how to like make someone
else feel at ease in situation truly and
you're the funniest most intelligent
glowing